(dramatic music)
(whip cracking)
- [Narrator] Wushu is the modern term
in China for martial arts.
It's especially beloved by
one wushu master in Macao.
He has made it his life's mission
to pass on the ancient forms of combat
that captured his heart as a young boy.
(dramatic music)
(foreign language)
Today, Master Pun runs the Macao Lo Lung
Sport General Association,
founded in 1938.
There are countless varieties of wushu.
One of these styles is Choy Li Fut.
(foreign language)
Other staples of wushu are the
dragon dance and lion dance,
which require an enormous
amount of physical strength.
More than 2,000 years old, they
are inseparable from wushu.
(foreign language)